o la soeur qui fait quasiment sais pas
si vous le voyez quasiment 31 degrés
c'est la folie alors c'est extrêmement
rare qu'on voit de nouvelles marques
secret arrive avec de nouveaux produits
et surtout une marque de smartphone
c'est très rare y en a mais c'est très
rare et ça se passe souvent du côté de
l'asie quand on en a une qui arrivent
ici qui est en europe presque en europe
en tout cas pas très loin qu'il est en
angleterre ne discutons pas des sujets
d'europe avec angleterre l emploi qui se
situe à londres et qu'en plus de ça on a
un interlocuteur qu'on connaît qui est
français et avec qui on a déjà eu raison
travaillé par le passé eh ben c'est
vachement cool parce que on apprend
plein de choses on reparlera de nos
sites lorsqu'on parle bien mais aussi
aujourd'hui qui lance son premier
smartphone pour la première fois il est
juste là on va le regarder ensemble donc
ça c'est cool donc abonnez vous tout de
suite dès maintenant parce qu'on dirait
un peu dans les coulisses du lancement
de nothing on va y aller demain matin je
pars jauzion mais je tourne tout suis ce
qu'on appelle sous embargo j'ai pas le
droit de vous montrer tout de suite les
choses donc je tombe vous voulez montrer
demain à 17h30 c'est la levée de
l'embargo comme ça vous sûr de tout de
même bref si vous regardez c'est déjà
arrivé et ça c'est cool donc ça veut
dire qu'on va reparler tout ça pour
aller voir loin dans des tailleurs si
vous vous souvenez nothing c'était
jusqu'à l'année dernière ce truc là ce
truc là c'est lé nothing ikhwan c'était
leur premier écouteurs ils viennent
d'arriver je vous raconte pas n'importe
quoi avec un smartphone tout nouveau
smartphone et ça c'est génial parce que
depuis super longtemps c'est le nothing
for one one pourquoi numéro 1 elle tout
change en fait ils viennent pour péter
les règles littéralement nouvelle boîte
nouveau format on dirait un espèce de cd
dvd avec un perroquet il aime les
perroquets avec un adaptateur secteur
qu'on peut pouvoir venir acheter en plus
sont là juste là et avait exposé une
coque de protection là dedans donc
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on fait et bien
aujourd'hui je vais vous montrer ce que
ma fille nous propose regarder le design
et la fiche technique comprendre un peu
ce qui se passe réellement et donc
quelques jours très peu de jours
rassurez vous on va se faire un test
complet on va tout regardez regardez ce
qu'il est intéressant ce smartphone sous
android ou alors pas du tout on sait pas
on est dans des frigos vides
[Musique]
j'adorais vraiment ce que vous allez
présenter proposé nothing can ya des
oufs avec ses ikhwan alors souvenez-vous
rire des reviens petit peu là on reprend
entre l'histoire les ikhwan s'était déjà
des écouteurs avec un design très très
différent c'était ça est en fait vous le
faisiez tourner un peu comme un âne
szpiner comme ça alors y avait un côté
un peu schizophrénique avec
effectivement toute cette partie là un
peu creusé surtout l'idée cissé qui
travaillent avec des suédois la boîte
c'est teenage engineering et qu'il leur
faut un design qui a proposé direction
artistique complètement différente donc
ça c'était un truc qu'on a vu l'année
dernière les ikhwan les premiers
produits de la marque la marque et
l'aquarelle la marque et la peine deux
ans elle a été créée il ya deux ans et
donc en deux ans et que vous entendu un
truc en partant de rien de rien du tout
eu ces les anciens ne se remplace donc e
en partant de chez wendel en créant
nothing et en regroupant des jeunes de
partenaires autour pour arriver
aujourd'hui deux ans peut-être non mais
moins de deux ans après avec un
smartphone là dedans avec un produit
fini avec une histoire avec un concept
avec un design et surtout et c'est tout
moi vraiment m'intéresse avait quelque
chose de très différent par rapport au
reste du marché aux autres acteurs c'est
ouf en deux ans vous partez de rien vous
n'avez pas de partenaire n'est pas
d'argent vous avez une idée dans votre
tête et c'est tout et deux ans après on
arrive avec ça je vais taper trop fort
dessus alors première phase avoir déjà
c'est un parti pris différents nous ont
mis un perroquet peut paraître un peu
con ce durant d'un perroquet mais déjà
ce que vous connaissez des marques bout
qui parle de technologie qui vous mettre
des perroquets assez peu donc le taux
est déjà est un peu un peu différent
alors attendez on va commencer par un
vote global met des coups qu on va le
mettre hors de cause et là comme ça vous
le dirai pas me les poser à coco qu'on
va commencer par ouvrir ça c'est
vraiment un truc qui nous intéresse
alors j'ai noté toutes les specs toute
la fiche technique donc je vais pas vous
la lyre n'y a aucun intérêt mais on va
essayer de comprendre et de commenter au
fur et à mesure qu'on va venir ouvrir
cette boîte alors c'est vrai que là
c'est un petit peu blanc donc on est un
peu blanc sur blanc mais pour autant
est-ce bien gras non ça ne me dérange
pas alors ouverture facile déjà là ça
c'est un truc qui m'avait vachement
frustré avec les juan parce qu'en fait
vous feriez vous arracher les languettes
et une fois qu'elle arrache et celle
usage unique voyez reste plus grand
chose à donner le conseil trouve ça cool
tu mets un peu frustré je pense place
est exactement la même chose à dire que
j'ai mon expérience de nos boxing je
prends voilà tous h olala ça me frustre
mais ça me frustre tellement d'abîmer la
boîte que je trouve trop cool je vais
peut-être pas l'ouvrir à fond c'est
tellement je passe à ce jusqu'au bout
pas olala ça me frustre mais ça ça me
frustre tellement tellement tellement de
perdre le truc m coco là comme ça vous
lever un peu dans plan c'est bon ok
allez on continue déjà je vois que là
j'ai le côté du smartphone donc les
mêmes limites je peux travailler mon
smartphone et le tirait déjà neuf ans
que l'expérience d'une boxing elle est
réfléchie regardez ça sort par là c'est
tout bête ça peut paraître con mais si
vous voulez quand on fait des boîtes de
smartphones on les ouvre sur le haut en
ahl smartphones on aime bien voir les
choses un peu différemment je ferais que
pour vous consommateurs c'est vraiment
cool donc l'âge et le smartphone fait de
voir alors attendez là c'est pareil je
peux le chopper là je peux chanter
comment la vache faut comprendre je peut
choper la ok je l'enlève là ok je
l'enlève
certaine patience ap hockey il aime
beaucoup je les ai vus déjà le jour sur
les séances de prix briefé je l'aimé
beaucoup parce que c'est très différent
de ce qu'on ailleurs et on fait ce qu'on
veut dire c'est les composants nus sur
lesquels ils sont venus travailler et
déjà une marque c'est chez un ami qui
avait tenté ça avec je sais plus quel
modèle pas mimiques chapelle classée
tekki voulu faire des composants faire
c'était de l'imprimé ce n'est pas
réellement les composants et là vous
avez vraiment du composant et à
l'arrivée un truc qui est très très
drôle je sais pas si vous l'avez regardé
bien regarder il dit pas on prend deux
secondes petite pause dans les
commentaires il ya un truc qui est
particulier est ce que vous l'avez
référence toujours aux animaux alors
c'est pas un perroquet est ce que vous
l'avez ça me sous les yeux ou pas prenez
deux secondes des marques lu mon
commentaire moi je lai vous l'avez ou
pas j'avais pas vu on me l'a dit votre
venue au caire garde est ce que vous le
voyez les défendre est ce que vous voyez
l'éléphant etc à trompe l'oeil les
pattes alors j'espère de que la
séparément un éléphant mais c'est un
petit éléphant le design il ya plein de
petits éléments comme ça qui sont
vachement drôle vous allez voir alors je
peux pas tout vous montrer tout de suite
parce que il ya vous savez ce que n'a
pas l'embargo il faut que j'y parle
encore le droit de montrer tout de suite
mais vous allez avoir tous des éléments
de lumière en fait une lumière qui va
s'allumer la lumière qui va s'allumer là
une lumière qui va faire tout le tour là
sur cette partie là il me semble qu'ils
aient aussi une lumière sur la partie du
bas à plat une partie universal partie
du bas sur l'éléphant est en fait ces
éléments de lumière qu'est ce qu'ils
vont venir apporter et bien vendu
rapporte à l'expérience pourquoi ces les
notifications pour vous mettez votre
téléphone vous le posez vous le posez un
silencieux là vous allez avoir
uniquement les lumières qui va venir
vous indiquer par exemple si vous
recevez un appel de la famille et bien
vous pouvez voir que ça qui s'allument
si c'est un appel du travail ça peut
être que ça si c'est un appel des amis
ça peut être que ça vous allez pouvoir
recevoir également des notifications
d'application avec différentes
configurations donc sans regardera le
nom s'appelle l'agly enterprise c'est
vraiment le nom qu'ils ont voulu venir
donner donc bon au delà du non je trouve
que l'idéal rigolote parce que une fois
de plus c'est du rock est un smartphone
c'est un smartphone c'est un form factor
de smartphone classique comment avec un
smartphone avec un form factor classique
j'arrive à apporter des innovations
j'arrive à porter un truc différent ça
c'est vachement cool donc là vous l'avez
en blanc mais il existe également tout
endroit où le truc est assez marrant je
pense qu'on a un peu pour tout le monde
donc ça voilà alors après il faut savoir
vous avez un corner dorian la 5e' si
c'est pas de glace si c'est pas vécu ça
comme un gars sympa c'est une question
de coût parce qu'on est sur un
smartphone milieu de gamme vous allez
voir je vous donnais le prix dans
quelques instants vous allez voir que
franchement ils sont vraiment venu tirer
les prix et ça c'est plutôt intéressant
votre truc qu'ils ont vraiment bossé et
qui coule c'est le petit 9 singh
voiliers qui est écrit là et qui ressort
donc ça reste très très très discret et
il ya un vrai travail qui bon alors ça
c'est toutes les normes ce et on obliger
le maître mais il ya un vrai travail qui
est fait au niveau du smartphone et des
composants apparent pour vous apporter
une expérience qui complètement
différente alors après son côté là sur
la tranche va vous aider à trouver le
bouton pour nuire l'allumé pour éteindre
c'est un très grand standard en bas on
va venir retrouver up ici le haut
parleur la recharge en usb c'est un
petit tiroir de quartier mais en fait de
voir en valent un peu plus loin parce
que je sais plus et c'est de la simple
de la double qu'est-ce que j'ai logé un
truc là qu'il a pu venir tirer donc là
je pense que c'est pareil attendez
accessories je sais pas si vous l'avez
là c'est un peu haut sur briand ce que
vous l'avez la voix c'est dur à avoir
accès accessories vous l'avez là il est
là accès services pour la vache dont
claire vous avez les accessoiristes
accessoires hop là alors qu'est-ce qui
nous ont mis là où alors même salle à
garder pour le tiroir de cartes sim est
en effet un peu trop près c'est très
différent on dirait une espèce de petite
diode en fait une petite led qui vous
servira envers votre tiroir de cartes
sim alors je prends je pique ils ont
vraiment été jusqu'au bout de la
démarche aussi très cool on accourt à
l'intérieur sim signe donc là vous avez
double carte sim 5 g 5 g stand alone et
non un stand alone également y retrouver
là donc ça ok on l'a ici alors ça c'est
marrant ça une fois de plus ils vont
vraiment à fond dans leurs démarches et
ça fait les objets collector je pense
que ce smartphone je sais pas ce qui va
se passer pour la boîte vocale et
réussir n'a pas réussi en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est que ça c'est un objet
de collection je trouve ce smartphone
parce que très différent parce que très
conceptuel pas de blog de change
intérieur double carte sim la petite
carte de garantie avec leur fameuse
police d'écriture ok donc c'est pareil
c'est très typé ils ont vraiment pris un
truc très blanc ça me fait penser un peu
il ya un petit côté un peu apple vous
voyez on ignore pas l'expérience donne
boxing quoique c'est un peu différent
parce que là pour le coup vous arracher
et vous pouvez pas venir créer l'objet
fermé alors que chez apple on peut mais
on est sur un côté très premium on l'a
vu les choses s'emboîtent regarder
parfaitement bien ça va là dedans c'est
vraiment il ya une vraie réflexion au
niveau du design et de la praticité et
pour le coup c'est vraiment une idée
qu'on me retrouvais je vous dise et
d'autres créateurs et notamment chez
apple qui est un peu fer de lance là
dedans donc une falaise ou vers saclay
fait comme ça et bien plus rien voilà je
suis arrivé au bout du truc je peux
regarder par là mais en fait voyez il ya
plus rien à l'intérieur donc là on est
vraiment arrivé au bout du jeune boxeur
avec double tiroirs donc prometteur way
up l'âme et accessoires et deuxième
tiroir mon smartphone qui va dedans en
fait c'est vraiment ça qui est marrant
parce que c'est vraiment de la boîte
jetables une fois vous avez savait
parler de sa femme comme ça je dis rien
il ya quoi comme intéressés parce qu'on
n'aime pas ça c'était dans l'autre sens
peut-être
voilà c'est dans l'autre sens donc ouais
ben là il revient donc ok donc ça c'est
pour le le smartphone de l'autre côté on
a vu qu'on avait deux petits boutons le
bouton de volume s'intègre en standard
sur le sucre le bêlement pas grand chose
le micro pour la réduction de bruit ici
il n'y a pas de prise jack et voilà
voilà un peu pour le smartphone alors
attend et on va continuer parce que ça
ne s'arrête pas là qu'est-ce qu'on
ad'autres côté on à l'heure ça je pense
que c'est l'avenir acheter en plus pour
leurs 45 watts est-ce que je l'avais
moins de 45 watts alors moi j'avais fils
à 35 33 watts on m'avait donné sur la
fiche technique et là je vois que c'est
sûr du 45 watts dont vous voyez il ya
une info j'avais pas ok moi c'est plutôt
la bonne surprise je peux venir le
recharger et six en quarante cinquante
ans c'est plutôt cool alors fait voir
l'homme boxing et ben c'est exactement
la même chose il ya ce côté je prends je
me je fais le tour voilà alors hop je
sors chez mon blog de charges assez
marrant tu vas y en a il ya un truc en
verre de sur le dessus un an ya rien
c'est drôle regardez regardez regardez
regardez c'est extrêmement drôle on voit
le contour en verre et on a l'impression
qu'on pourrait l'enlever alors qu'en fin
de ces plastiques que je peux enlever
tout ce que enlevé comme ça et ça me
fait un objet en verre et une fois de
plus je pense que c'est vraiment la
patte de tyne engineering qui est
vraiment venu leur proposer un vol de
soulager son hockey qui est venu à
proposer un truc hyper drôle ça fait y'a
côté tellement années 60 je trouve dans
leur objet mais c'est beau c'est design
c'est efficace ça pèse lourd le bloc est
un peu lourd mais bon c'est pas grave
profond à l'intérieur là on a fait le
tour il ya plus rien juste les documents
garanties de sécurité & company sont
obligés de m et puis je démarre une
coque de protection ici fait de voir
même bazar alors ils sont vraiment fait
plaisir vraiment fait plaisir c'est de
voir
chaque peuple a comme ça on va tout
jeter et la coque de protection bien
évidemment totalement transparente parce
que le smartphone est transparent et que
on veut garder l'expérience qui est très
cool très très cool vraiment et là c'est
pareil a plus rien alors comme on est
sur un concept de bois de jetable parce
que sans vraiment faire on peut les
balancer ça voilà ça c'est fait ensuite
qu'est ce qu'on a alors attendez on peut
pas faire une review l'on peut contenir
allume un smartphone là on est un
smartphone qui fait 193 g ce qui n'est
pas très lourd on va enlever la coque
jamais très après pour le protéger c'est
pas très lourd 193 g ok ça me va bien le
truc et son dû faire aussi bien côté et
très éco responsable on est sur de
l'aluminium qui va être 100% recyclé et
50% des plastiques que vous avez à
l'intérieur ils proviennent des
matériaux biosourcés est recyclé donc à
une vraie volonté de recyclage ici ok
autre truc il faut connaître c'est
l'écran alors l'écran entre un peu dans
l'aspect qui vous intéresse et de l'oled
en fait c'est de l'oled flexible
j'aimerais bien l'allumette pour qu'on
puisse voir l'oled flexible parce qu'on
est sur un écran regardez là on a bien
la police d'écriture en a fait on est
bien sûr un écran plat mais il est
flexible pourquoi juste pour pouvoir
venir vous le rapprocher un petit peu et
réussir à voir pouvoir aller au plus
loin en tout cas au niveau du design de
l'écran il ressentit va ressembler façon
aussi par semaine soit pas très bien
français donc là le design hockey hop
ils arrivent english lots on retrouve
vraiment leur police est très cool alors
non nous on se met en français france ok
bonjour salut toi connexion aux réseaux
mobiles on verra ça plus tard il vous
indique tout plutôt sympa connexion wifi
alors ça j'ai même pris fille donc je me
connecte raiffeisen est flexible ça
c'est du 6 55 pouces et quand même des
grands écrans mais c'est ce qu'on
retrouve actuellement écran certifié hdr
10 + 1 milliard de couleurs full hd plus
de 1400 par combien 1680 pixels ah je
vous le dis 402 pixels par pouce bon
jusque là tout va bien copie des données
non on part de vierges et alors on nous
annonce ici c'est ce qu'on nous annonce
assez vraiment avoir à vérifier du test
donc on en reparlera dans quelques jours
nous avons une luminosité de 500 nits
avec un pic 1210 on va se mettre par des
formes temps de charge y en a plus en
plus il y en a que je ne connais pas et
qu aux ja je ne connais pas si riche
mail.ru
prix 16 h au cerveau farceur tellement
que je connais pas on va se mettre du
google après à vous de voir ça c'est la
définissent un codeur je mets mon code
code de sécurité déverrouillage par à 14
ans emprunte digitale en lui on peut
venir le déverrouiller soit avec le
capteur d'empreintes digitales soit
directement avec la reconnaissance
faciale celle android ans un très très
grand classique pas de souci donc repro
figure très très rapidement ok afficher
toutes les notifications ouais ok on
passe l'assistant qui est ici en plus ce
qui est intéressant c'est que en place à
on verra plus tard ils nous ont mis ok
on s'en fiche ils nous ont bien sûr un
taux de rafraîchissement de 120 hertz
adaptative donc vous allez passer de 60
90 à 120 hertz c'est lui qui le fera
intelligemment donc ça c'est vachement
bien pour le gaming analyse des données
allez on va partager navigation system
navigation par gestes au le bouton
navigation par gestes bien évidemment
bienvenu balayez vers le haut et on peut
y aller voilà on arrive sur l'interface
donc là vous voyez déjà on a un truc qui
a certes à la sortir qu'en fait vous
avez la même distance de bord ici d'un
côté ici en eau et sur le bas on a
vraiment un truc est équidistant entre
ce que vous avez là est-ce que vous avez
là et ça ils le font grâce aux oled
flexible vient de plier pour l'emmener
le plus loin possible
alors le truc qu'on voit c'est qu'on a
débord quand même qu'on remarque bien
sur les côtés mais comme tout est
symétrique je trouve pas ça grave
l'autre truc qu'il faut savoir ici c'est
comme vous êtes sûr de l'android stocks
eh bien vous avez je vous le disais
votre taux de rafraîchissement regardez
je montre je peux pas aller plus loin
parce que je vais pas faire un test des
smartphones les journaux juste
l'interface on retrouve bien la police 9
singh l'idée en tout cas c'est
effectivement de retrouver cette police
cantonale la police on a la petite
caméra qui disparaît ici alors là on est
en dark thème antenne sombre n'ont pu la
voir également en termes clairs et vous
avez aussi si vous êtes un gamer un taux
d'échantillonnage tactile de 241 6 pour
ça c'est intrigant standard 10 haut
parleurs stéréo alors c'est le haut
parleur duo ici là vous allez retrouver
qui servira de haut parleurs de renforts
comme sur tous les smartphones sont un
petit peu classique sinon celle aux
parieurs du dessous l'acquis des clous
par leurs principales notes du bluetooth
cinq pointes 2 et 3 micro lance haute
définition pour vos appels et compagnie
donc sans les regarder tout ce qui les
intéresse nous ici réellement c'est la
performance sous le capot on a un
snapdragon de chez qualcomm 5 778 gg
pour gaming plus plus pourquoi bah vous
savez sur des versions un petit peu
délité mise à jour est un peu plus de
performances et ce qui est intéressant
ici est bien c'est que qualcomm
snapdragon 178g plus gravé par tsmc il
est gravé en 6 nanomètres on passe un
petit peu le truc et surtout ce qui va
ce que ça va venir apporter c'est telles
celles et ceux qui ont les maîtrisent
aujourd'hui je pense les meilleurs au
niveau la technologie de gravure au
niveau d'ebit puces et ça permettra
d'avoir un smartphone qui va venir
évitez la chauffe entre autres on
regardera ça c'est vraiment l'idée le
chantier fait ici vous avez soit 8 soit
12 dis pas de bêtises c'est bien ça giga
de reims il a répété hier 5 ça c'est
vachement qu en termes de rapidité on a
vraiment ce qui va bien à l'intérieur
que vous avez soit 128 soit 256 giga de
stockage c'est lui à fès 3.0 vous l'avez
vu non extensible regardez on retrouve
là la géolocaliser on retrouve là
l'écriture je change de fond d'écran
parce qu'on voit pas bien là la date du
jour ok donc ça c'est plutôt sympa
ensuite qu'est ce que vous allez où
j'avais une grosse batterie de 4500
milliampères l intérieur on m'annonçait
de la recharge fait à 33 wade voyez j'ai
un bloc de charges 45 watts donc bon on
va dire qu'on a de la filière 45 watts
globalement on va retrouver de la charge
son fils ces deux-là 15 soit charge cuit
et vous avez de la chance d'inverser 5
watts à ok et si vous faut des blocs de
charges compatit quick charge 4.0 voilà
ça il faut le savoir côté expérience
c'est de l'android très proche de
l'android stocks c'est à dire qu'android
pur et dur on va juste retrouver un
petit peu eh bien je dirais cette police
d'écriture propre à nothing et quelques
petits éléments de l'interface ici
glyphes les glyphes interfaith mais que
je vous montrerai un peu plus tard lors
des phases de test parce que j'ai pas le
droit tout de suite de vous la montrer
donc on regarde fera ça d'ici quelques
jours donc une fois de plus venez vous
abonner ce n'est pas déjà fait tout en
sachant et le matin je vous le dit texto
il annonce trois ans de mise à jour
android ont cru pendant trois ans vous
êtes soirée tranquille que vous aurez le
dernière version d'android et puis
quatre ans de correctifs de sécurité
dispo tous les deux moi donc ça il ya un
truc qui est aussi très rassurant et je
trouve ça plutôt intéressant alors après
il ya un truc qui est cool c'est au
niveau de la photo alors vous le savez
je vous le dis souvent il ya beaucoup de
marques qui vous mettre trois capteurs
des x 4 capteur à l'arrière dont 200
vraiment quelque chose et le reste c'est
vraiment du bullshit ici nothing qui
sont dans cette idée de se dire on va
pas en mettre des tonnes pour en mettre
des tonnes et acheter un capteur macro 2
mégapixels qui ne servira à rien si
c'est juste au marketing donc en fait
qu'il vaut mais deux capteurs principal
et ça sera largement suffisant et une
fois de plus dans les bras tarif il est
hyper canon dans quelques instants deux
capteurs de 50 méga pixels sont pas les
mêmes capteurs le capteur principal pour
votre grand angle c'est un capteur sony
c'est lit-et-mixe 766 c'est une trés bon
capteur de sony donc y'a pas de souci
là-dessus il si on ouvrira enfin 1.88
stabilisation optique s'habiller sons
électroniques en dise l'offre c'est un
capteur de samsung c'est le jn c'est le
ji n 1 de samsung ici on ouvre à 2 20 à
2 214 d'angle de champ de vision et une
stabilisation ici uniquement
électronique plus servira également de
faire de la macro à 4 cm on voit la fin
dans quelques joueurs des phases de
tests et avance à une caméra 5
mégapixels c'est lit-et-mixe 471 et en
ouvrage 2.45 c'est marrant parce que ya
beaucoup de marques qui nous disent pas
qu'elles sont les capteurs eux ici on
voit que c'est les anciens douanes place
et d'envoyer onepoll s'ils avaient
vraiment l'habitude de venir montrer de
données entre à toutes les specs et
garde un peu cette idée en tout cas où
cette façon de fonctionner ici vous
pouvez faire de la vidéo à l'arrière
jusqu en 4k 30 et à l'avant en 1080p à
30 également alors à savoir également
que sur un smartphone qui est certifié
ip à 53 certifié aux éclaboussures
attention on n'ira pas aussi loin une
certification ip68 donc ils p53 on a le
nfc compatible google paye et on a
également du wifi si donc ça ça va
plutôt bien lors les tarifs devraient
donc parce que je les ai l'attention des
prix au liban barbe et c'est là où ça
devient intéressant parce que ce
smartphone il a un truc très sympa une
nouvelle interface notre façon un petit
peu de concevoir de smartphones notre
expérience ça reste aux smartphones on
est situé ici dans le milieu de gamme
alors il ya plusieurs configurations et
on a trois pour tout vous dire 828 c'est
là où s'écoule vous êtes à 469 euros on
est à moins de 500 euros largement à
moins de 500 euros 828 franchement c'est
une super config on aurait dit un 8,64
vous aurais dit n'y allez pas 828 avec
aujourd'hui tout ce qu'on met dans le
cloud vous n'aurai absolument aucun
problème donc si vous voulez ce
smartphone 469 euros franchement c'est
extrêmement abordables 8 256 on double
le stockage on est à 499 euros toujours
en dessous de la barre un peu symbolique
des 500 euros ça c'est cool et 12 256 on
augmente la capacité drame pour plus
l'expérience de gaming si vous voulez on
passe un peu au dessus on est à 549
euros mais ça reste très cohérent et je
trouve ça intéressant parce que ce
smartphone en fait il est cohérent on
voit qu'on est sur un smartphone qui
vraiment là pour gaming faisait sa
tournée plein de jeux d'époque jd
asphalte 9 pas de souci là-dessus donc
ça c'est vachement cool vous avez un
mode jeu également mais on regardera
sans détails un peu plus tard pour voir
s'ils répondent bien s'il chauffe pas
tout ça le regarde mais libye elle est
là la promesse elle est là est ce que je
trouve cool et ce que je trouve
intéressant c'est que ça ramène un petit
peu le smartphone à des tarifs un peu
plus raisonnable avec un truc sexy on a
un smartphone qui est sexy pour autant
est ce qu'il sait faire de bonnes photos
je ne sais pas encore pour autant est-ce
qu'ils chauffent je ne sais pas pour
autant est-ce qu'il tient la charge je
ne sais pas mais ça je vous le dirai
dans quelques jours autre truc quand
même qu'il faut savoir et là j'ai pas le
tarif c'est que ça il faut venir
l'acheter en plus donc c'est quand même
un petit prix vous pouvez nous retrouver
après des chargeurs coup de charges 4.0
qui seront peut-être un peu moins cher
que ça je sais pas j'ai pas le tard et
tout de suite ça sera vraiment à avoir
que ça viendra présenter et puis
obligatoire il vous faut une coque
transparente on ne peut pas avoir ce
smartphone sans coque transparente
puisque ça viendrait complètement pété
l'expérience qu'on a ici donc ça
n'aurait aucun sens le mieux c'est quand
même de venir le prendre à la main ici
tout en sachant qu'on a dû sous les 10
c'est du corps nus gorilla glass 5 c'est
pas du cices c'est pas du virus donc ça
fait quand même pas mal de venir me
protéger donc voilà pour tout ce que je
voulais venir vous dire il raconté voir
cet homme boxing avec vous on a un
éléphant derrière on a un perroquet sur
le smartphone on a une nouvelle histoire
qui s'écrit on reparle de nothing d'ici
quelques jours le temps de le tester il
vous donnait un peu mon retour il vous
dit réellement ce qu'ils en pensent et
puis autre petit point je sais pas si
vous l'avez vu si vous êtes encore dans
leurs cordes et la vidéo marqué le moins
commentaires il ya un autre élément qui
moi m'a vraiment sauté aux yeux lorsque
je les ai vus comme ça est ce que je
joue un peu plus que ça voulait dire est
ce qu'il ya un truc qui vous saute un
peu aux yeux ou pas du tout je vous le
dit ça sans dépenser une petite bombe
vous savez comme dans l'est comme dans
les jeux vidéo un peu à l'ancienne
convient lui même la petite mèche et la
bombe noire alors allez blanche cette
version blanche eut posé la question à
l'équipe de nothing ils m'ont dit non
non non on n'a pas du tout prévu de
mettre une bombe ce n'est pas du tout le
but mais il ya plusieurs personnes qui
est long on dit donc il faut croire que
c'est un peu injuste tout le monde allez
savoir s'ils veulent pas venir
inconsciemment à dynamiter le marché du
smartphone on n'en sait rien on va dans
ce sens très intéressant et pas vous
est-ce que ça smartphones qui pourrait
vous tentez ou pas il faut savoir qu'il
sera dispo le 27 juillet 2022 sur le
site nothing point tech et sur amazon
dès qu'il sera dispo je vous mettrai le
lien en bas dans la description dites
moi vous s'il peut vous tentez vous
beauté ou alors absolument pas marquer
moi ça en commentaire et puis nous on en
parle très vite très bientôt on va
continuer de s'intéressent à ce
smartphone parce qu'il ya un design ya
autre chose en plus qui les deux de nos
fils et pas uniquement un smartphone ce
n'est pas uniquement une marque de
smartphones qui fait vraiment de
l'écosystème avec des écouteurs et ils
le disent attention on dit quoi ils
veulent avoir un écosystème de produits
et l'idée je cite intentions je vous
l'aï dit mais ses rangs de la
technologie m à nouveau voilà donc on va
voir si il nous amuse avec ses produits
en tout cas moi je trouve que l'idée est
là l'idée sympa et puis quand on teste
beaucoup de smartphones comme moi il ya
un moment c'est toujours un peu la même
histoire et notamment dans le milieu de
gamme il faut vraiment on a cherché dans
le très haut de gamme pour trois trucs
un petit peu différente août un peu cher
là le budget reste maîtrisée même si 500
balles quasiment ça reste quand même
beaucoup d'argent mais ça reste maîtrisé
je trouve cool trouve intéressant à vous
de me dire ce que vous en pensez si vous
pourriez succombé et on en reparle dans
quelques jours je vous embrasse en
quelques jours ciao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]